c'était le 2 décembre dernier la ville
californienne de san bernardino était en
état de siège
une attaque terroriste faisait quatorze
morts et 22 blessés
sayyed farouk et tachfine malik se
disait inspiré par le groupe armé état
islamique pour commettre ces meurtres
étaient ils les seuls avait t-il
planifier d'autres attaques
seule piste l'un des iphone de farouk
récupéré par le fbi mais impossible
d'accéder à son contenu sans connaître
le mot de passe ici après dix tentatives
le fbi a et ne trouve pas la combinaison
toutes les données du téléphone seront
effacés cet exemple avec 1 avec quatre
caractères les tests chimiques avec des
méthodes de traditionnel ça prendrait 5
8 cinq ans pour trouver alors c'est sûr
que le jeu via ils veulent pas prendre
cinq ans alors ils veulent bail passé le
6 tentatives
le pdg de apple prétend que des chiffres
et la combinaison est impossible le fbi
s'est donc adressé à la cour fédérale
qui lui a donné raison
forçant à paul a créé de toutes pièces
un logiciel pour débloquer le iphone de
la terreur mais l'entreprise refuse
d'obtempérer
sous prétexte que la sécurité et la vie
privée de tous ses clients seraient
alors en péril une réelle possibilité
selon cet avocat spécialisé en
protection de données et de vie privée
ça ouvre une très grande porte
une fois que à pau développe et ouvre
cette porte là et son argument est je
pense à l'argument qui sied c'est à dire
tous les gouvernements au monde vont
constamment venir frapper à notre porte
pour obtenir cet outil leur permettant
d'accéder au contenu de tous les
utilisateurs d iphone au monde son
compte et que la technologie pourrait
tomber dans les mains de pirates
informatiques ou de malfaiteurs la
bataille entre apple et le fbi est loin
d'être terminé puisque l'entreprise
entend contester la décision de la cour
est l'enjeu est de taille
qu'est-ce qui a préséance la sécurité
nationale ou la protection de la vie
privée après les excès de la cia et de
la nfc dénoncé par snowdon les autorités
américaines marchent sur des oeufs dans
leurs enquêtes pour déjouer le
terrorisme
ici frédéric arnould radio canada mon
frère